The other day, my friend texted me.
(phone chimes)
[Hey there sexy mama baby llama lady]
Clearly, it was not meant for me,
so of course he said..
[Whoops wrong person! My bad haha]
But whenever someone says, "Whoops! Wrong person!"
or "Ahhhhh! Wrong thread..."
there's always this weird side of me that thinks,
"You're a liar.
Liar. You're a liar. You're a liar. You're a liar."
Right? I mean, am I the only one who's just totally
skeptical whenever you say "wrong person"?
Speak.
(deep garbled voice) The encrypted file "Viva Oscar Viva"
has been transferred.
Transferred..to who?
Wait..who is this?
This is Agent Anna, who is this?
Woops.
Wrong number.
(phone beeps)
(phone rings)
(deep garbled voice) Hello?
You dialed me on purpose just to let me know
that you cracked the encryption on my file.
What? No, why would I do that?
To play mind games with me.
To break my spirit.
To undermine my authority and throw it in my face.
That makes no sense at all.
This was just a horrible mistake.
(dial tone)
But then..
whenever I accidentally text the wrong person,
I'm so paranoid that they don't believe me.
Oh shoot..
Nonono, augh..
"sorry wrong person"..
(beep) Hey it's Lisa, you know what to do.
Hey! Lisa, this is Anna, I just texted you,
but it was actually--it's the wrong Lisa, so that was totally..
my bad. So just ignore that text, okay? I'll see you soon, bye!
Lisa..
(muttering)
(whoosh)
"Dear Lisa,
The SMS message from me to you on 6/23 at 12:24PM
was a mistake, I'm so sorry."
Okay.
(panting)
Oh god..
OWL!
(hooting)
TAKE THIS MESSAGE TO LISA!
AUGH!
But I feel like my frantic need to set the record straight
only seems more suspicious.
(screams)
WRONG PERSON!
What about you? Have you ever texted the wrong person?
Or received a message you were not supposed to get?
Or maybe, just maybe,
you do it on purpose..
as a passive aggressive power play.
"Thanks so much for proposing to me today honey!
I can't wait to get married to such a
handsome, rich, and well endowed man."
"Oh noooooo
so sorry that was meant for my new boyfriend.
My bad"
(chuckles)
You know, I told my brother about the premise for this video,
and instead of like, laughing and relating to it,
he just said
"You are a very paranoid person."
So I'm hoping that someone somewhere across
this WiFi connection can actually relate to this.
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome Gotham.
I'd like to thank Lundberg family farms for sponsoring today's video.
Do you have mental mishaps?
Like you can't find your glasses when they're on your head,
calling your boss "mom",
or even maybe just replying all to an email
containing juicy government secrets.
That stuff happens when you're undergrained.
Lundberg can help. Their tasty line of whole
grains of variety rice-y goodness, quinoa,
and organic rice cakes can get you to grainiac clearance.
Lundberg has been providing whole grain goodness
while protecting and improving the environment
with their eco-positive farming methods since 1937.
Proving this:
Good doesn't go out of style.
For more grainiac fun and facts, go to beagraniac.com.
Lundberg family farms, declassified.